guglielmo certo modo disperato che è
successo alla situazione attuale questa
dopo che hanno fallito miseramente in
cucina lui al mio enrico abbiamo deciso
di versare noi al franco ecco qui il
menu bistecche di angus provare se poi
abbiamo motivo nerello mascalese
eccezionale
l'agrume dopo la carne come si dice no
da sempre quel tocco queste
cioè io ho accettato la tesi della cia
casi madonna si sente puzza ma che cos'è
questa puzza che carte fatto che c'era
mezza e boscaglie manco voce signore
degli anelli
nessuna e itv woods non lascia stare
non ci pensa gabriele no ragazzi per
piacere fatti di fare quello che voglio
è tutto vieni divenne che ne pensi
quando si attacca la mer i soldi
portafortuna dal ris porta soldi che sa
combinare questa foto spinacine che
pensi cosa faccio solo di una cosa con
la mano degli stivaletti donna e
bistecche per un attimo come andranno le
bistecche senza mani come saluto
ferruccio la rotta gianluigi sovrano un
coperchio altra padella un minuto e
mezzo un minuto e mezzo la carrà nesta
cruda ma grasso no quindi porno caldo
quando è pronta a due minuti di forno
che scioglierà che ne sai tu di ste cose
sicuramente lo ha chiesto il macellaio
stesi e mezzo canto dall'urto ci pensa
lui forza cucina come pensi che sia il
piatto la pensa rapporto tanto
eccezionale valore seppur e cattivo
guarda se provini st carne visto che
sono sempre io quello che cucina lui
neanche il forno s'accende quindi gli ha
chiesto a telecamere spente di accendere
il forno questa pratica difficilissima
ma già stato rimpiazzato medici erano
destra che accendere perché lui io
camicette non è che non è pratico ma
presto ma faccio le braccia fare a meno
ecco qua acceso sono un po carico già
avviene negli specchi dianese perché
sono venuto di corsa ha comunque ho
portato avanti il biglietto voglio far
vedere che un sero cacchio
ciao ciao diciamo che cosa abbiamo qui
no non si tocca e da dove serve tipo
scarichi ma la madre
questa è la larghezza questa è una
seconda pelle
sta bene deve faccio vedere ma non erro
responsabile delle conseguenze
[Applauso]
beccati a queste bellissime ora vive a
kabul
qua devo girare guardarli come ti devi
stare oddio se fa la mia va da maria
coprire
no non era secondo in fondo al mar come
il fuoco e perché mamma mia comunque di
famiglia che cosa sempre piaciuto
conte opinione e mezzo la bistecchina di
ammoniaca
mettete lo scudo
magari tutto questo sport 1 e poi un
fornello gol al calore settoriale non
c'è mai un canone di ciò che quando
tornero blanc hanno vissuto da vicino la
questione sta impazzendo
stati scritti natura solo ecco la misura
di protezione meglio gestite in maniera
gianluigi collo brava a cucinare della
famiglia
vi dico solo che io sono il secondo se
fargli capire il livello di stile ma
vogliamo che il vino che da un pò più si
è un po più cosa tranne umana per il
video vero mai procedere laddove la mira
con questo no quelle reti che si fa
sotto ma purtroppo dell'opinionista
chiaramente molti somellier tiranno è
quando si ci sono insieme dr non serve
solution non sapete quanto brucia non è
ancora finita la guerra settimane
lanciata per ora esclusa casa sono il
macello perfetto ma che ti devo
ammetterlo stracittadina tavola si
chiama che mi sembra che qui una
maglietta superamenti che se bruci basta
il muto e addirittura c'era come oggetto
che sarà quello di messi in proprio non
senso il dolore del bruciore
no quello no in un modo google in questo
vediamo chi capita no io non ho notte
non ci sia la mamma che mi metti il vino
da me non sta facendo niente oggi fa
meno male faccio sempre con sé tutti i
giorni guarda che il cardinale
mamma mia che furto in forse come dicono
a questo pranzo in famiglia che è una
meraviglia
cin cin
per finire la ricetta messo il mio
collaboratore di altri restiamo sereni
che terrà due minuti di forno alto casa
io rimarrò qui ragazzi tempo del corpo
si pensa che tu assistente non vedono
resistente dell'unico svegli o qualcuno
perché è massiccia crescita è veramente
beh se non c'è sì questo è quello grosso
si mangiano quello prof sociale dalla
legge
la pista è casa mia con sale grosso
centro della visita per terra
direttamente cioè prendere notizie
[Musica]
aspettatelo passo sulla gamba allora
devo dire che è leggermente sotto la
spina cina con sabina cina aveva una
marcia in più è vero la mediocre come
per uno sforzo però non problemi
trovajoli mangiato coi piedi da terra
lombarda un burro scende da solo dalla
portiera le le le mele l'elefante giù il
boccone mentale giusto ce lo faccio se
mi parli sconcezza simile a tavola e per
così la testa c'è una testa quindi è
nemmeno testa voglio dire una cosa ogni
anno appena
il pacco di pan di stelle non è vero
dopo i concerti pan di stelle quando in
realtà pronunciati marino allora qual è
il vostro frutto definito l'anguria per
me la clementina ragazzi per te ok la
bara per la finale se volete ancora di
questi video mi raccomando scrivete qui
sotto il vostro frutto preferito non è
del video che ci abbiamo saputo
l'abbiamo detto che a 50mila
devi mangiare per gli animali quella
nelle stalle tranquillo non arriverà mai
50 va bene ok facciamo 50.000 ricatti in
questo sentiero arrivano a 60.000 genova
è in silente 7 fatto per questo divario
che ha da dire il cibo degli atti che si
prega ama che pure può aprire questo the
man mano che avviene grazie ai genitori
poveri animali un pezzo è schifoso
malattie fan di thiene adesso non sempre
qualcosa da bambi stelle non abbiano
ripreso ma non ti ho visto mangiando
io oggi sciopero faccio la pastorizia
faccio un cavo di rete parola cosa che
posso dire e tuo fratello
avremmo potuto prendere una bistecchiera
in più anche per noi non siamo due gocce
d'acqua sono vorranno ancora il
biglietto si reca il nostro tenendo cioè
devo ancora fine un po di cose ammazza
tenente questo è il mio fratellino più
piccolo se fosse bello degli altri
aspettati razione degli altri qui
abbiamo il meno importante partire dal
basso enrico poi qui c'è gold o il più
importante babbo natale jami lavinia e
guglielmo purtroppo dei voti o levate
prego ma non è simile passaggio
hai ucciso le mie orecchie dove stiamo
andando di male non vanno dagli
scannerini e stavo andando a divertirci
siamo vicino al rosso pazzo un episodio
di vita buttata dopo il cappotto dirle
come sto non ero erni benissimo cosa
vuoi che mi sta puntando cosa cosa
colpevole cosa ci si aspetta che non gli
si vedono le bellissime la raccolta
quello che ho fatto allora di oggi ho
fatto un errore ho cercato di lasciar
dormire di più enrico gianmarco e non li
ho voluti schiavizzare per aiutare ma i
milioni di solito mi sono sbarcato tutto
da solo ma io sono solo un uomo umile mi
sono dimenticato tra le molte cose ho
dimenticato la scheda per registrare
l'audio per vedere chi siamo
la linea giulia detto giulia lo
conosciamo tutti
purtroppo all'inizio artista la cosa
davide l'erede misterioso di questo
posto
no apriamo la era primo la realtà il
tulipano nero fratello
non c'è e abbiamo deciso di mettere in
piedi un santino ci serve nella foto del
pool c abbiamo foto di pulci free gente
allora c'è gente più né medesima che
sono favolosa no dai non è vero che la
juve non ha detto questo sono
imbarazzato a fare
barack è roba marina bionda parliamo di
quanti anni fa tanti per tenere alta
l'attenzione vista sta aspettando
gianluigi che torni con la sd che andato
a prenderlo possiamo fare come nel
vecchio varietà dove si fa un momento di
show e quindi la vita ci mostrerà come
fa la spaccata no dai ragazzi che mi
imbarazza mi mettete a fare queste
catene giulia cucinerà per noi un dolce
cielo già pronto ma perché non ce la fa
dato prima momento che c'era fegato
mimetici ti faccio un atmosfera ho
portato del torrone artigianale non
avrebbe rispettato nel secondo
mattinata migliore è chiara che una
ripresa migliore si chiama colonscopia
in questo caso
[Applauso]
mammamia volato
da fighetti ma sta cosa che io anche non
ci capisco nulla quindi sto prendendo ma
questo è l'unico momento in cui ho avuto
mai s'è spenta il cervello che mi è
venuta mentre stava urinando una sorta
di idea giusto sì sì ok è un'alternativa